how can the government or policies hate
Middle America
how can the government help Middle
America let's let's think about that
part right there how can the government
help Middle America okay so a perfect
example to give you here
um I don't know if we talked about this
last time did we talk about the 63 000
salary or no I don't think we've talked
about I don't think so okay so Adam
Vinnie Tom Rob all of you here I want
you to think about this answer if you
make sixty three thousand dollars a year
you love your mom your father passed
away is no longer Independence sounds
like you you make sixty three thousand
dollars a year what percentage of your
money are you comfortable giving to your
mom to help her out
if you make 63 a year which is roughly 5
200 bucks a month what are you
comfortable giving to your mom to help
her out
a year if you make 63 63 000 a year I'm
asking a sincerely the average American
you probably don't have enough money to
give your mom anything I agree but give
me a number to save five thousand
dollars ten percent tithe for your mom
Tom 500 bucks a month is probably what
it would take to help your mom get over
anything okay so let's say 500 bucks a
month which at sixty three thousand
dollars that's about 10 that's about 10
right okay sounds good watch this do you
know if you had eight zeros to that
sixty three thousand dollars what number
you come up with our federal expenditure
do you know out of our 63 6.3 trillion
dollars a year on federal expenditure
how much we spend on entitlement
programs do you know what the number is
uh What's the total number out of 6.3
trillion what percentage we spend on
entitlement problems or what dollar
amount out of the 6.5
probably closer to three trillion 3.3
trillion dollars we give to entitlement
program half of it let me give you
another number on this context and since
we're on this context in 1940 okay no
not 1940 go to uh 1960 years ago
whatever 60 years ago is what 1960. in
1960 1950
um what percentage of kids born in
America you think were born to single
mothers and what year is this go to 1950
what percentage of kids being born in
America were born to single mothers I'll
tell you ten percent I would say it's
half of that probably four or five
percent it's exactly four percent okay
you know what that number is today
probably like 40 it's exactly 40 wow it
went from four percent to exactly 40
here's a question for you now obviously
give or take someone's gonna say it's
not exactly 41 or 39 all I'm saying to
is the one from four to forty percent
how do we get here
how do we get from four to forty percent
welfare Queens actually think of do you
know we are one of the worst countries
if not the worst country in the world
and kids being born to single mothers
why so so uh so uh uh Biden comes out
and they want to add another 2.6
trillion hours because they want to
increase the amount of money we're given
to single mothers with kids here's how
the policies got started what caused
this The Surge is based on two things
one in 1935 FDR when it came out with
Social Security New Deal he also came
out with a new deal he also came out
with policies to give money to single
mothers okay
who had kids okay these are single
mothers maybe they lost a husband War
something was going on but they're like
we have to take care of them fine we
have to take care of them no problem
then in 1965 lb Johnson LBJ takes it to
a whole different level and then you see
the skyrocketing and they said here's
how we're going to invest into
eliminating
people being poor the Great Society
Brandon can you send me that one chart
on the flip on what happens if the
investment we made and the amount of
debt we increased to help out the poor
to eliminate the poor brand and if you
know what chart I'm talking about just
text it to me for me to show this to Rob
so Rob can show it up this is not the
one but he'll send it to me right now to
see it it took 55 years for us to find
out that that investment we made in
single mothers became a bad habit and
now it's costing us so much money that
we can't get away from it anymore we're
spending 53 percent in entitlement
programs so going back to what we're
talking about no the other one that
shows Rob the other one that shows the
one that's declining and the other one
that's increasing I think you know which
one I'm talking about uh uh here I'll
send this as well to Rob but the other
one I'll send Rob I want to send this to
you so the audience is watching this
they know where to go get the source to
to do their own research on what we're
talking from four percent to 40. so so
going back to Adam your point about
what's to do there's two things I think
about one is what we can do as
individuals as people that have families
to inspire others yes you got to make
more money yes you got to spend less
money and the way the government can do
it guess what government's gotta also
make more money and they gotta also what
spend less money yeah we keep
spending more money and we're making
less so Middle America's look at this
this is less than four percent of 1950s
you see the person a number of single
unwed birth rates we're above 40 percent
we're at 41 this is not good so by the
way somebody's watching and saying
how do I do do we get off the topic and
are talking about this what happened if
my mother if my mother tried to
discipline me single mothers say Hey you
better do this I'm not listening to my
mom what are you talking about no I'm
going out I'll be home at 11 o'clock you
need to be on by this time she can hit
me that gets to an age that the hitting
doesn't hurt anymore and she kind of
sitting there saying what do I do now
you either have to marry somebody to
discipline me or you have to call my dad
but you guys are divorced so you guys
don't talk I want to do whatever the
hell I want to do side of 1.8 GP in high
school what if there was some order in
the house what if somebody didn't come
into my life to give me I saw a picture
the other day that this African-American
man in school is buying suits for kids
teaching them how to shake hands
teaching them how to take care of
themselves freaking awesome I want her
to find out who this guy was to buy him
a nice suit or two for himself and take
care of him but we need more of data
like this to look at and realize listen
we're screwing this thing up here's the
investment oh my God I can't wait to
show this to you guys Rob I'm gonna text
this to you folks if you see this we
have this article that's going to be
coming out here soon this research we
did great job shout out to Brandon on a
great job he's doing with the research
Rob if he can pull this up so we can
show this this next one is the real one
I want you guys to see it shows like
when you invest remember yesterday I was
talking about 401K why aren't you guys
investing into the 401K to match and all
this stuff that we have
short term what do people say uh it's
not what's the big deal I'm not going to
make that kind of money I'm not going to
do this it's just your turn look at this
right here total means tested welfare
spending and official poverty rate from
1947 to 2012. so look at the poverty
like to the left you see how high it was
percentage of people that were poor at
during what era this is great depression
post-great depression okay and the
amount of money we spend on welfare
look at the break even
you see when they cross paths what year
is it 1990 yeah 1992 yeah okay 1992 yeah
that takes about 55 years but then guess
what happened the poor level stayed the
same look at our look at our costs for
welfare guys this didn't work
this whole thing about the plan that FDR
came up with ended up being a show
and you and I are paying a price for it
and Lyndon Johnson what did what he did
in 65 that also didn't help look at the
spike after 65 you see 65. so it was
gradual from what FDR did to 65. but
look what happened after 65 boom it just
goes both of them combined we became a
spending machine country and we're not
watching what happened to China and
Japan we are next if we keep going like
this this is a serious issue this is not
a hypothetical when I'm going around
talking a different podcast this last
week I did podcasts a few different part
one podcast I did with Tom Ford I think
his name is Tom Ford from Forbes he says
look I disagree with almost every single
one-year policies obviously he's on the
left and we're having a comedy says well
you know how about this and how about
that and I talked to George jenko and
we're talking to Graham Steph and George
ankle about to get married wants to have
a family Graham Stefan about to get
married wants to have a family and this
other guy had two daughters that talking
to I said listen I don't care if you're
a Democrat or Republican this shit's not
working
this spending money to try to save
poverty is not working we need to step
out of the way and let people figure it
out four percent to 41 what happens when
most kids are raised by single mothers
boys are going to be doing whatever the
hell they want to do makes make cities
unsafer you can't look at this and say
well that's not fair and that's racist
and that's this and that's that no
problem go back to your problem go back
to your uh what do you call it um
ideas and see what has done to your
Society you go ahead and do that keep
spending the money see what it does to
you and then one day we're going to wake
up I'm gonna say damn it look at this
stuff but this is proven this is not a
hypothetical this is proven data on what
we did and where we are today and either
we're going to do something about it or
we're not so and Pat you said you're the
first thing if you were in charge it
would be with number one is just stop
printing money I'm going to change
incentives is the first thing I'm doing
okay well like like for instance what
would you want one major one how do you
how is your life right now how do you
feel right now with yourself your
confidence your personal life right now
I'm good you're good yeah okay what
changes have you made in your life you
give dramatic changes you made pre-vt to
now pre-vt um I don't drink I'm I'm
privy to you were drinking of course
okay yeah not like a maniac but you know
I go out I drink I social Adam was like
uh drinking obviously going to church
spending money unless stupid stuff I'm
not going out I'm not doing anything
crazy but uh yeah just life is
Everything's changed
everything everything Health different
way you're eating you know the other day
George is like hey why does the vanilla
videos on steroids yeah everybody that's
just hater the first thing we have to do
is we have to change the incentive
programs that we have in America our
incentive program which is our tax
system when you work for a sales company
whatever their comp structure is is
going to produce behaviors our tax
system is producing the behavior of
single mothers
our tax system is producing the behavior
of not going after your dreams why
because the government's stealing that
away from you by giving you money so you
don't have to work your ass up to go
after your dreams our tax system is
producing
super super super wealthy people and
it's producing the middle class to be
eliminated there is no incentives our
tax system is making the big companies
bigger and the small business owners to
disappear just 40 years ago we have 50
plus companies when we wanted to buy
weapons or we wanted to buy planes
today's those 50 plus companies are five
five we are now with what's going on
today in the economy these bigger banks
are buying the smaller Banks what is
that doing fewer options to go to Banks
as being nationalized the tax system in
our incentive system is destroying the
middle class and the only way to address
that you have to make some dramatic
changes and that is going to infuriate
so many people at the top that have
control so for a person to do that the
current system is not going to be
sustained for a person like that to win
so this is why I kind of like what Vivek
is talking about this is why I like what
rfk's talking about that's why I like
the fact that Trump's pushing the
envelope even The Descent is out there
hopefully hopefully they're able to give
their message better tonight tonight or
tomorrow night tomorrow night is going
to be an innovate we're watching it
right we need somebody to come in that
can't be bought that's not for sale
there was a there was a one of the best
moments in the debate
was when Trump and Hillary are going at
it and Anderson Cooper asked a question
and says taxes if he can pull this clip
up I don't know if you know which one
I'm talking about yeah he says hey uh uh
uh Donald uh Mr Trump you know your tax
records show that you paid nothing in
taxes last year you haven't paid taxes
for this many years and he says yeah
absolutely my goal is to pay the least
amount of taxes possible so are all of
her donors yeah and then she said but
here's the thing if Hillary wanted to
fix it how come she hasn't changed that
for 30 years because her donors won't be
happy and this is why I haven't taken a
single penny from the donors because I
can't be bought I can't be controlled
she can't
it it the only reason somebody will
listen to that and say that's
is because you're such a Democrat that
you're not open to the idea of an
opposing argument that logically makes
all the damn sense in the world one
person has bought the other person is
not is this the one that you're talking
about play this money I think this is
the one go ahead and play it on taxes
where the number one issue on Facebook
for the first time the campaign the New
York Times published three pages of your
1995 tax returns they show you claim to
960 million dollar loss which means you
could have avoided paying personal
federal income taxes for years you've
said you pay state taxes employee taxes
real estate taxes property taxes you
have not answered though a simple
question did you use that 916 million
dollar laws to avoid paying personal
federal income taxes of course I do of
course I do and so do all of her donors
or most of her donors I know many of her
donors her donors took massive tax rate
last month yeah it unfortunately doesn't
show the next 30 seconds because you
know she he says if you had 30 years how
come you've not done anything about it
our incentive system right now sucks on
America so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here